[Música]
hoje como todos os dias eu acordei me
arrumei do meu café da manhã e peguei o
ônibus pra vir pro plano piloto é onde
eu trabalho estudo e ao chegar na
rodoviária é eu perceber uma
movimentação diferente acontecendo né na
região da esplanada dos ministérios no
congresso nacional se uma movimentação
uma energia diferente
eu fiquei curiosa não estava muito bem
naquele dia sabe quando se acorda minha
sim
aí eu pensei será que essas pessoas que
tomam as decisões que impactam as nossas
vidas vão fazer hoje
que tipo de decisões elas vão tomar que
vão transformar minha vida
aquilo ficou na minha cabeça quando ele
já estava um pouco atrasado eu falei ah
vou dar mais uma olhada aqui até que
houve uma movimentação diferente né não
como no museu nacional da república nem
vítimas faixas coloridas nenhuma pessoa
saiu da rodoviária para lá e aí eu falei
nosso quinto diferente né eu não tinha
me dado conta que tinha uma agenda
diferente até pensei ah deve ser mais
uma dessas manifestações que acontecem
todos os dias né e aí eu fiquei curiosa
mas algo me inquietava para que eu fosse
até o museu e aí no caminho eu decidi eu
decidi né
sair da rodoviária e andando e andando
até que eu vi várias mulheres negras
eu tinha eu nunca tinha me dado conta
que eu nunca via tantas mulheres negras
nessa região da cidade que não fosse
fazendo trânsito nep do trabalho
trabalho muitas vezes pega ou trocando
de ônibus e aquilo me chamou a atenção
porque elas eram as mulheres ao sabe
alegres elas são instrumentos nas mãos e
elas fazem um percurso o percurso da
rodoviária do plano piloto até museu de
uma forma muito alegre
né e aí eu falei bom vou seguir mudando
muito curiosa é até que os eu me
aproximei do museu eu encontrei algumas
moças eu perguntei o que está
acontecendo gente aqui hoje elas a é o
festival atividades o maior festival de
mulheres negras da américa latina e tem
shows é oficinas conferências
internacionais mostra de filmes e aí eu
falei do nosso que bacana então eu
pensei bom já que eu estou por aqui né
era de graça eu resolvi me aproximar e
quanto mais eu me aproximava do museu e
reconhecia daquelas mulheres que eu via
né
e aí eu via mulheres com várias texturas
de pele
neco várias oportunidades de pele
textura de cabelo elas elas eram muito
alegres ela se cumprimentavam elas
conversavam entre elas e aquilo me
chamou a atenção de um jeito que eu
falei nossa acho que vou ficar por aqui
hoje né e à medida que eu ia conhecendo
esse espaço e eu ia entrando me
familiarizando com aquelas pessoas elas
podiam ser minhas irmãos minhas primas
minhas tias né porque era tão tão
parecidas comigo o cabelo né
é o jeito de falar o jeito de andar o
jeito que ela conversava então ela como
se tivesse em casa sabe que aqui foi
muito marcante para mim é e aí uma das
coisas que me chamou muita atenção é na
medida que eu ia conhecendo essas
pessoas e e adentrou nesse espaço é o
afeto né era feto era a estética tinha
umas de cabelo azul outro esse cabelo
rosa esse cabelo rosa ela era muito
estilosa sabe aí ela estava muito
tranquila do conjunto com o jeito dela
assim aquilo foi me cativando m
cativando mas ainda foi quando eu era
uma criança uma menina né ela estava num
cima de um palco uma fazenda a
apresentação onde já temos cinco aninhos
mais ou menos
e ela já se importava como se ela fosse
uma rainha sabe como se ela fosse é
e eu era uma rainha né ela era muito
tinha muita certeza do que ela estava
fazendo e ela tinha muito orgulho do
cabelo dela né é aquilo que eu falei
nossa aqui que bonito né a gente é tão
difícil ver essas meninas negras né é
aceitando o seu cabelo né é tanta coisa
acontece na escola que faz com que elas
não num lance tão bonitas não se sintam
felizes por serem quem são nem e aí eu
lembrei até de uma notícia que tinha
visto recentemente que o brasil é um dos
50 piores países do mundo pra feminina
você já imaginou ser uma menina negra né
e ela me mostrou que é possível superar
isso porque ela era muito empoderada ela
já ela era muito firme naquilo que ela
estava se propondo com cinco anos e
aquelas experiências foram marcantes
assim claro tinha um homem também né eu
claro tive que reparar nos homens uns
boy magia também bem legal assim a louca
e aí quando eu me toquei que eu estava
num espaço que eu nunca tinha estado
antes
sabe que eu podia ser exatamente quem eu
sou e eu podia ser uma mulher negra é
que eu podia ser uma eu pude usar o meu
cabelo do jeito que o uso o meu vestido
ninguém me jogada de uma forma diferente
porque todo mundo ali era como eu
foi uma das experiências mais
transformadora da minha vida né
naquele momento percebi que existia que
existia já pararam para pensar que tem
gente que acorda de manhã e não sente
que está viva
não sente que existe pois é isso
acontece com muitas pessoas negras né
vítimas de racismo vítimas de todo tipo
de discriminação né
e aquela experiência real já estava
quase na metade do dia eu já tinha
pensado tanta coisa bacana e até que eu
entrei no auditório que aliás era uma
história muito parecida conhecer que o
auditório do museu nacional da república
e este auditório e nesse palco tinham
várias mulheres que eram inteligentes né
mulheres que eram referências
luta há muitas outras mulheres algumas
eu nunca nem tinha ouvido falar ou então
nem eu nem sabia que existiam
e essas mulheres elas eram jornalistas
ela vieram arquitetas elas eram
cientistas elas eram economistas elas
eram 11 juristas né eu me toquei que
naquele momento eu podia ser o que eu
quisesse até artista poderia ser um
artista se eu quisesse que todas elas
ali elas eram aquilo que elas exatamente
queriam ser né
e essa experiência motivadora
experiência de muito útil muito amor e
muito de muito carinho de muita
cumplicidade de uma com a outra de muita
riqueza também né e aí eu decidi que eu
fiz o que eu ia fazer uma oficina de
turbante e fiz uma oficina de maquiagem
e foi a primeira vez que eu me senti
ainda sabe eu sou uma mulher negra gorda
periférica eu quase nunca tinha tido a
chance de existir né
e nesse momento eu percebi que eu podia
ser tudo aquilo e ainda mais do que eu
quisesse ser né e aí é uma das coisas
que mais me chamou a atenção foi uma uma
poeta uma poetisa aliás uma poetisa que
declamava vários versos eu nunca tinha
me dado conta eu gostava de poesia
porque eu nunca me via representado nas
poesias era tão distante de mim e ela
falava das minhas dores
nela só ela falava das linhas das dores
dela que também eram as linhas né do
tanto que é difícil uma mulher preta no
país racista né e aquilo foi uma na das
experiências mais marcantes nem talvez
tenha sido a parte que eu mais gostei
foi a partir da poesia porque é eu deu
até vontade sabe descrever algumas
coisas e isso pra mim foi libertador né
e depois eu participei dos shows e
tinham artistas de cuba estados unidos é
república dominicana no brasil né
mulheres brasileiras de muita força e
muita representante
idade e aquela experiência né o dia já
estava terminando e eu tinha me dado
conta que tinha sido talvez um dos dias
mais significativos e mais importante
pra mim né então eu aproveitei os shows
e eu curti como se não houvesse amanhã
dancei mesmo me joguei na pista né e
enfim essa não é essa não é
necessariamente a minha experiência com
atividades que começou um pouco antes
quando o festival ainda era uma idéia né
é uma idéia de uma grande amiga e uma
das mulheres negras que eu mais respeito
né chamada jaqueline fernandes e esse
festival foi realizado justamente para
preencher e pra dar oportunidade para
encher essa louca essa lacuna e ao mesmo
tempo dá visibilidade à produção
intelectual e artística das mulheres
negras né e já são mais sujas mais de
nove anos estamos caminhando para a 10ª
edição e ao longo desse desses anos né
mais de 200 mil pessoas passaram pelo
festival eo e muitas atividades
aconteceram e muitas mulheres foram
enquadradas nessa muitas mulheres hoje
estão aí e graças a esse passo inicial
que a atividade deu ele acontece aqui em
brasília é um presente para a nossa
cidade enfim é eu queria pra finalizar
aproveitar para convidar vocês
conhecerem o festival atividades que
acontece em brasília todos os anos no
mês de julho e profissionalizar
eu queria dizer que eu jonara silva 30
anos mulher negra existo e nós
seguiremos existindo
[Música]